this question is tricky and the answer
doesn't help you very much
right you look at it and you're like
this is no help at all right so
classic um approach is to take the
question
and to boil it down into something which
is um
is more handleable so actually the
question is very the question is very
well crafted
because it is numerically simple but
it's just
hard enough that you can't do it
exhaustively right so what you do is
you take a question like it that you can
do exhaustively and you see
how the logic works out so let me give
you an example
okay um instead of going up to four
let's just go up to three
okay so the question becomes i'm going
to use the digits one to three
okay i'm tackling just three because
it's much more
handleable exactly you can list them
which is exactly the point
and when you list things you can see
patterns that's why it's so useful okay
i'm gonna use those numbers there's not
many
and i'm gonna see what happens okay i'm
gonna add them all up and that's what
i'm looking for the total stock
okay so let's just quickly write them
all out now even before i start to write
them out you can actually tell me
already
how many possibilities how many
arrangements are there
wait there are three alternatives it's
three
three three which is also three
factorial which is six okay
and i will write them out for you
they're really easy to write
three there you go six options done
okay and as you said because you can
list them
now you can start to spot some patterns
okay so here's the first thing i noticed
okay there are three factorial
permutations
okay so if i were to scale up if i was
going to do the digits one to five four
instance there'd be
five factorial permutations no problem
okay
now let's start to think about how can i
add this up in a systematic way
in a logical way okay well let's just
have a look at
the column by column i'm going to deal
with them column by column because i
have to treat the columns differently
okay so for instance let's have a look
at all of the ones
in the units column okay now i see one
two of them now here's my question when
i see two of them why are there two
and in what situations with the number
of ones in this column change
okay now here's the first thing i
noticed there are three factorial in
total
right numbers here to add up but i'm
only interested in the ones
that's out of three alternative it's one
third of the numbers
can you see that a third of these three
factorial numbers in this column
are ones okay so therefore
how many ones are in this column and the
answer is three factorial on three
it's a third of them right
if i said to you if i said to you i have
um i have two thousand students in the
school
right and i want to pick out um
no that's a bad example sorry i have 52
cards in a deck
okay and i want to pick out you know how
many aces oh sorry
how many hearts are there how many
hearts are there and the answer is it's
not just 13
there are four suits right there are
four suits so that means
exactly a quarter of my cards will be
hearts right so if if there are four or
ten views
then i'll divide by four right and there
are three
terms here right so how many of these
one two three four five
six numbers are there that will be ones
and the answer is
divide by three just like i divided by
four to get the number of hearts i'm
going to divide by three
if you like my ones and my suits right
i've got three suits to choose from
and there are three factorial cards in
my deck all right
now three factorial of three that's
actually two factorial isn't it
okay so when i add up all of the ones in
this column
right um the the sum of
all of the ones in the units column
right it's going to be 2 factorial times
now each one is worth one right
and they're units so it's one it's a
bigger
now the reason why that looks a bit
silly but when i go to the next one you
see why it's important right
if i do all the ones in the tens column
okay how many ones are there in the tens
column
and the answer is exactly the same
number because i'm doing the same thing
i have the same number of permutations
to choose from and the same proportion
of them will be ones
so it's still going to be two factorial
each one is still one but now they're
all worth
ten and then i do it one more time for
the hundreds
right so there's still two factorial of
them there's still one and they're now
worth so if i was to work out now what's
the sum
of all of the ones in in my picture
right it's gonna be i'll take out a
factor of two factorial
i'll take out a factor of one and then i
can add up
these guys which is 111.
okay so if that's what all of the ones
are then i can work out what all of the
twos are
how many twos are there as i go through
each column and the answer is
still two factorial they're now worth
two each
but when i add up all the units tens and
hundreds i'll end up with 111.
and i'll do the same with the threes
there's still two factorial now there
were three
you still got 111 so now i factorize one
more time
to get the sum of everything
two factorial um
a hundred tens units and then
i say well i have one in here two here
through there
and so now you see from a problem that
is manageable
you can scale up from there and then you
could scale up to
however much you wanted but you now see
why that's it too
it feels like it should be a three but
it's not
right um and you now like this i think
that one makes more sense once you
you start adding them up you see where
it comes from and then you see why
that's not just an arbitrary thing
i'm pulling things together